il signor ne ho scoperto che se mi
pettino i capelli in alto vengono fuori
così non so perché quelle tutti ragazzi
e benvenuti a questo video sono fa vj
egiziano in un uomo prima di cominciare
ragazzi questa settimana vorrei partire
con una fan abbia settimana come al
solito ma la fama della settimana di
questa settimana è parecchio strana
perché allora in realtà la fra della
settimana è stata vinta da de beers che
ha fatto questo disegno sei fatta una
foto e poi ha fatto il disegno sulla
foto è figo c'è un'idea della madonna
volevo commentare tra l'altro il fatto
che lei ha fatto baby e una youtube di
arzana youtube è perché ha fatto
l'adesione dello speed art del di questa
fan art la cosa che mi ha fatto morire
dal ridere e assurdo mi sto guardando il
video tranquillamente ad un certo punto
vi compare questo devi ma ma perché fra
tutte le migliaia di foto che c'era ma
proprio questa il disegno comunque figo
ti ringrazio derby per il lavoro che hai
fatto siccome sono anche uno youtuber
bravo a disegnare adesso ti faccio io
una fan art quindi adesso io disegno de
beers
[Musica]
eccola perfetto rilascio comunque link
della sua sfidante nella descrizione che
sceglie leggere soltanto la parata la
settimana questa settimana qui ho visto
un made it fatto su di me che è
veramente fuori di testa praticamente io
ho pubblicato questa foto l'altro giorno
che avevo i capelli così perché mi sono
svegliato così una ragazza non so chi ha
fatto questo che cosa [ __ ] troppo figaro
ristorante la settimana come avete
passato il capodanno mi fa arrivati un
miliardo di commenti io come avrò
passato mai il capodanno cioè baldoria
festa a casino
gigi d'alessio comunque ho visto più
ubriachezza quella sera che in discoteca
quindi ma comunque sia passato il
capodanno con la mia famiglia con i
genitori
c'era anche il mio cugino quello piccolo
quello di di questo video allora adesso
giochiamo us land e con mio cugino ho
fatto anche una partita a calcetto
durante capodanno ovviamente ho vinto io
ma chi sono
visto che questo blog sta diventando una
roba del tipo metto clip a caso mettiamo
quest'altra cliff a caso di mio cugino
mi piacciono le termiti
ora che ho finito di parlare di mio
cugino che non frega un cazzo a nessuno
passiamo oltre
ora ragazzuoli visto che sono anni che
non faccio ormai uno scherzaccio dei
pacchi facciamolo sto benedetto scartato
dopo secoli miliardo ragazzi ce n'è uno
che grosso come mia nonna non so se
normale cosa grazie ho sempre desiderato
questo ora faraldo della madoff sfiga
quando è gradita jolo e bellissima
grazie chiaro favi spero che arrivi in
tempo per natale c'è scritto grazie
notato insomma sia arrivato in tempo per
natale però non l'ho aperto in tempo io
vabbè la prima adesso caro non c'è
problema recupero figlia ma maneggiare
con cura attenzione sigillo di pannella
che cazzo è un ordigno nucleare un
regalo ma non ci credo ma è la stella
nera grazie sfidavamo ragazzi nova ves
carta jolie natale in diretta ragazzino
anno dopo perché prima voglio vedere
cosa c'è qua non so se questo potrebbe
interessarti lo presi su ebay ma non
l'ho mai usato a ed è sintomo la tua
spettatrice alla madonna spettatrice
avevo mai sentito con venti anni più di
te si rilegge in stupisci tra 20 anni
più di porca era cioè i 40 anni zia mar
piede nella fossa program scherza via mi
ha scritto una lettera chilometrica una
mia fan di 40 anni grazie
non penso di avere fan di 40 anni ha
detto grazie mille valentina stella nera
grazie vale adesso la pronti questo se
ai 40 anni mi immagino che sia un regalo
da 40m quindi una macchina allora è una
credo sia qualcuno ha voglia di
spiegarmi cos'è
è un pene a posso creare delle cose
frigo comunque quei regali c6 fare per
il tuo albero di natale
cos'è la fo che vuol dire tale è
bellissima tanto che ti piace scrivere
ti piace l'orrore ti piace hello kitty
hello kitty meters cielo a dorothy pre
carità di dio mi ha regalato una penna
di hello kitty è una penna or.sa proprio
ma che cazzo è ovvio che figo poi
decidere anche con le pugno muovere che
figlio e per concludere ragazzi abbiamo
questo che l'ultimo parco che più di
natale di così si muore non è una maglia
la paghi console è in cui sino fatto a
dio ti abbiamo abbiamo venti anni di
differenza ma sposami lo stesso non
ricevevo regali così figli da mai vedo
che sarà difficile ragazzi battere quel
pacco però passiamo al prossimo perché
sennò rimangono lì a morire sul lettera
aprire in diretta assolutamente perché
personale che succede scoppia una guerra
tutta voi poco di facco ragazzi per
questo che è una renna bello me la metto
quando vado a rimorchiare le donne
spesso peggio vedi come come il
rimorchio l'equipe di 40 anni con quel
così ciao ragazzi ho finito con i pacchi
ringrazio perché la non può che non ne
ha primo 15 ci sarà ci sta se perfetto è
un pokémon irata un pokémon porca vacca
passiamo al fa vi risponde che è meglio
era noto che non facevano scartato un
caso allora ragazzoni la prima domanda
arriva da jelly bean games mi chiede mai
smesso di guardare anime asi rotta è
vero c'è stato un periodo almeno tre
anni fa buoni ne guardava un botto poi
ho smesso perché con i video la scuola
non ce la facevo stati età nient'altro
forma malapena riusciva a dormire
sbagliato ho iniziato a guardare
qualcosina tipo vabbè ho rivisto per la
sedicesima volta deathnote tutto quanto
ma sto guardando steins gate è così che
rimorchiava le donne guarda adesso come
sono ivan dietro le quarantenni fa vi
basta con due giorni che non fai per
questo commento qua l'avevo screenato
perché mi ha fatto ridere la settimana
scorsa ha avuto la febbre per due giorni
non ho fatto video
lei ha vestito fari pasta sono due
giorni che non fai vedova ha scritto
basta come se fosse come se fosse una
tortura quello stato due video preferito
del 2015 e non tuo non mio
non mio credo quello dove obama
cantalino il miglior video mio credo
quello su gta 5 a corda ragazzuoli
passiamo ad affari non andati oggi
perché mi è venuto in mente di nuovo gta
5 è una serie che che è finita che vi
piacerebbe rivedere non lo sa un
episodio a caso tipo che ne so the
forest gta su motori di i temi una serie
che vi è piaciuta tanto che magari un
episodio se lo faccio ancora fatemelo
sapere nei commenti quella più votata ci
farò sicuramente un altro episodio che
so li facciano concludere qui il video è
stato bello riscattare i pacchi anche
perché è sempre natale però che vi sia
piaciuto cose se vi dove piaciuto a
lasciare un commento
è un mi piace anche la pagina di
facebook come non i video tratte
inscriptions e riti di scappini ci
vediamo prossimo video ragazzi